It's mentioned in surah Zar chapter
number 39 verse number 41 that we have
revealed to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him the Quran so that he may
instruct the humankind not only the
Muslims of the Arabs but the whole of
humankind. So the glorious Quran because
it is the last and final revelation from
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala to the last
and final messenger prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him. It was not revealed
only for the Muslims or the Arabs. It is
revealed for the whole of
humanity. The glorious Quran is a
proclamation to humanity. It is the most
positive book in the world. It's a
fountain of mercy and wisdom. It's a
guide to the erring. It's a warning to
the heless. It's an assurance to those
in doubt. It's a solace to the suffering
and a hope to those in despair. Whenever
you have an equipment, normally along
with equipment, you get an instruction
manual and more complicated the
equipment, the more requirement of an
instruction manual. For example, if you
buy a DVD
player, it says if you want to play the
DVD, insert the DVD and press the play
button. If you want to stop, press the
stop button. Don't immerse it in water,
it will get spoiled. Don't drop it from
a height, it will get damaged. The dos
and don'ts of that equipment, that
machine is mentioned in an instruction
manual. If you allow me to call a human
being a machine or equipment, you'll
have to agree that the human being is
the most complicated machine on the face
of this
earth. Don't you think it requires an
instruction manual? The instruction
manual for the human beings, it is a
glorious Quran. The dos and don'ts for a
human being is mentioned in the last and
final revelation the glorious Quran.
Allah says in the Quran in surah mulk
chapter number 67 verse number
two it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds. So this life that we are leading
in this world according to the last and
final revelation is a test. We human
beings Allah our creator says in the
Quran the last and final revelation that
this life is a
test. Allah has created death and life
to test which of you is good in deeds.
What is the purpose of our lives? Why
are we here? What are we doing? Have we
thought about it? Have we thought about
that? What are we doing in this world?
What is the purpose of our life? Allah
says in surah zarat chapter number 51
verse number
56 that we have created the jin and the
men not but to worship me. So the main
purpose of the human
beings according to our creator is to
worship Allah subhana wa t'ala. The
Arabic word used in the Quran is abd.
The word
ibada is used coming from the Arabic
word ab which means a slave. When we
follow the commandments of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala, it means we are
doing ibada. If we are doing the things
which he has said is compulsory, we are
doing ibada. If we abstaining from thing
which is haram and prohibited, we are
doing ibada. So when we follow the
commandments of Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
when we pray, we are doing ibada. When
we give zakat, we are doing ibada. When
we fast, we are doing ibada. When we
don't have alcohol, we are doing ibada.
When we don't gamble, we are doing
ibada. When we don't tell lies, we are
doing ibada. So ibada means following
the commandments of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala as true servants of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala and the
cornerstone of the Islamic faith and of
the Quran